all right good luck wait where's my type
thing
there we go we're gonna see a king's
gambit on Sea Kings gambit oh let's play
c5 Waits
okay file games on oh dear what should
we play oh we played that weird line
last time let's play let's play
something standard on the sea takes g4
we're playing some mainline oh man I was
teaching a student this earlier today
yeah 6c fall
this was all still kind of prep so on
castling Roxy it's still Theory b5 still
very much Theory every oh he played a
three yeah it said a three which is
weird but I'm getting used to it let's
play 505 going for the throat h4 no fear
of my pawn storm was h4 I want to play
b4 like before open files bishops on t7
so he doesn't have a 4 it's maybe for a
be no a takes b4 Wow 92 mmm
night a - so my pieces need improving my
rooks uncie ate my pawns gonna fall
unfortunately I don't know if I care too
much the bishops on d4 still the Queen's
on D - okay and I have to think there's
like Bishop h6 ideas someday it's Queen
c7 maybe Queen c7 Bishop e6 let's do
this I want to play Bishop e6 and
someday mate on c2 such a safe move King
b1
yeah the been fine we'll draw there
should be six takes takes let's do it
six pre-move f e6
I just want to remove the Bishop from b3
it's one of life's best defenders I
might be sacrificing my pawn structure
so I lost upon but I've won I have like
three I have two half open files one
fully open file on the Queen side I have
a battery with the Queen and the rook
have ideas of like night maybe 97 could
be interesting but the bishops on d4 I
could play Queen a 525 play rook b8 play
rook AIDS and so many options I could
play e5 rook a8 seems like the most
flexible
I want them bring the other rope to like
probably be eight and I want to bring
the Queen to a one and just mate wait he
said it's a b3 it said b3
what does b3o b3 is a move actually I
forgot the bishops on g4 it's already
dreaming of like tatics Queen Queen b6
an attack tonight so working takes okay
let's play Queen b6 attacking attacking
the knight oh no the Knights defended by
the bishop oh my queen my beaut
did I just do another boat has gambit I
think I may have done another boat has
gambit down the Queen I'm trying to
complicate things attacking the Queen on
D to the Kingston b1
this is actually a really fascinating
position I may have sacrificed a queen
on purpose but maybe is accidental maybe
it was being influenced by the majestic
bow tez but I have ideas I'm threatening
I'm threatening the Queen was not on e4
is such a monster I get the knight the
dragon bishop breathing fire that rook
on a eight now this is beautiful
it's much more beautiful than the last
thing that I said which was beautiful it
might be dubious but dubious things can
also be beautiful I think
I think there's only one move that I'm
scared of I'm really hoping he doesn't
play it but he might play it please
don't play it obviously he sees the
threat I'm tightening May than one here
with her k1 for those of you who didn't
know which is why I play Queen b6 it's
not easy for a white to find a move
actually I don't think wait the rooks on
d1 they worked on do you wanna and oh
there's a very interesting line I mean
he has to be running well on time I
would think it should there should be a
function where it like announces a time
when like a player's below a minute or
every minute that like passes
lot of time is passing what's going on
now I guess he's still thinking maybe I
can take a nap before well he made the
move there's a d4 so blocking the meets
yeah the sad thing is I'm gonna be down
a piece yeah that was just a terrible
idea
I have to take on D - let's put you 5 5
we're still trying to fight resume org
FB 8 5 lady 5 so rugby 7s
I'm sure I'm gaining time wait rook rook
e1 but both rooks can move to e1 rook e1
and now I'm confused Knights on d5 I
don't know where that removed but I'll
guess it's somewhere on the first rank
probably one like rook 81 let's play
rook be a seven maybe I'll play e4 at
some point
sneaky ideas c4
whoa c4 nice move let's play rook p7
play rook a be a next attacking b3 if b4
I probably have like a 6 or d3 ah nice
move so I can't play what can i play
can't quite get away with that I want to
play you for doesn't work but you 6 6
attack the Knights 93 right now maybe
for me for there's still a pawn on f3
so still apollomon up 3 and my e3 let's
play King f7 just want to centralize the
key tonight last night
f1 what does this move 9 f1 key me seven
days dicho that's solid was very solid
to play Bishop h6 Bishop h6
six tried to use the bishop like my pawn
on e4 ie for another good move take
stick sticks
okay let's try D 5 D 5 expanding in the
center very risky even trying to great
ideas open the position 95 Wow
so he doesn't take XE 5 maybe I can take
on c4 yeah D take C for attacking the
rook and also threatening taking on b3 I
assume the bishop song b2
so if B takes c4 I can take on b2
yes I'm I have some hope like the center
is kind of crumbling but queenside is
also vulnerable see three another bad
move but now I can take on b3 with check
c b3 c b3 okay so white has I'm counting
correctly I have two pawns for a knight
why only has the three pawns in the
kingside like H 2 G 2 and F 3 but my
pawns are kind of all over the place
ie 65 and B three Knights still in c5
the rooks on it works on c3 okay so Rick
takes b3 hmm complaint Bishop f4 but
then there's g3 what to do maybe just
Bishop Bishop g7 is ugly King g7 is
uglier Bishop takes e5 s coming
unfortunately so maybe like rook a8 rook
e8 actually looks reasonable I want to
play rook a to invade on the second rank
I mean black can take the e pawn I'm
still not sure like I'm assuming the
rook is on e one okay now the Knights on
c5 mean Yorick see Saturn I guess oxys
are they trying to fight
okay take c5 rook takes e5 I think it's
said but now I have Bishop g7 ah but
then there's he can take on e6 it's not
good
so rook c6 I guess he's defending
attempting to defend so I just lost now
pawns are equal like three on three he's
just up a full night's holding on for
dear life
Bishop e3 that's terrifying
wait Bishop a3 oh my gosh that's time
trouble rook takes a three and then king
d6 I think King g6 was a knight spins
the rook has nowhere to move on the
fifth rank I forgot about that
King c5 no my beautiful rook King d5
rookie takes c6
kingi 5-3 c5 okay trying to run and take
pawns I have one precious Bishop left on
the board or play King f2 next oh I have
to mmm ship g5 family by 55 age 65 oh my
gosh King F - oh no King g3
what takes h7 this is so bad exam t3
takes t6 oh my gosh 2 3 7 10 G 2 G 6 t3
d7 G - oh my gosh she is promotion Queen
King f3 no where's my king king afford
one can advise anyone
hey 6n f - z so teflon okay six what
kingi to king f1 oh my gosh I think I
resign o king f2 if I resign that's too
difficult I was typing King up three
good games
good game John Davis oh my gosh that's
so difficult I was trying to make moves
but yeah this office this whole boat s
gambit was slightly questionable I guess
that's a definition of a boat s gambit
Bishop d4 is good I actually didn't see
Bishop d4 coming we played some actually
played some mainline a3 i think is
actually one of the better moves
I think 95 in 95 and also maybe e fives
one of the main lines I mean I was
feeling good around here and then I got
a little bit too creative including b6 I
was trying to make it seem like i
blundered it was actually probably just
a blunder
um first I was thinking queen a sudden
but then Bishop takes a seven that
blocks my rook from meaning yeah I
should probably I don't know what I
should do here maybe just rook rook fp8
looks more attractive you actually think
this is a great line for whites yeah
if you know how to defend like this
Bishop on b3 is quite annoying but still
looked interesting in this position I
was actually thinking queen g4 I was
calculating Queen D for some funny line
Knight c3 King c1 and then it's like
Bishop h6 ideas or even just taking on
d4 and rook a1 in the end
why not Queen a5 yeah Queen 85 also Oh
Queen 85 yeah
no the bishop controls a1 and the light
controls a - maybe it's it's better
okay chat this is fun